public art has a lot of power one
can create something and instead of walls it
becomes a window
[Music]
my name is work álvarez i was born in the
city of juárez and grew up in el paso
texas
i am known as the shaman of
graffiti always that state  inspired by
nature the basis of what is
beautiful of what is perfection
and I like to go to the place
where the wall is I see the space I feel the
energy and I start to paint and from there
something is born the things I paint are like  a
form of intuition that has to do
with psychology with the mind with the
emotional states of urban space
we are in bushwick painting a
hummingbird vision as a symbol of the third eye as
a moment of reflection in nature
[Music]
I have always been interested in
pre-Columbian cultures the knowledge
that they have left us I bring
with me and I begin to deposit that in
different places where I make my
creation
by capturing art in the public space
the com  unity begins to be empowered
then it begins to feel that
this art is
theirs living here in new york is very
magical for me to capture my work in the
city where graffiti began
art is a universal language an
image can speak to them  to everyone
[Music]